[Music]
we saw some pictures of you in Italy
last week we recognized your friend that
you were with from the Phillies at
Lowe's Cointreau video is it felices los
dos Latin superstar maluma keeping it
super sexy with model Natalia bata leak
in his video for the smash hit felices
los cuatro which has over a billion
views and Counting but more on that
later the pair was recently spotted
packing on the PDA in Italy
so are they mixing business with
pleasure I'm happy that's one of the
things that I had that I consider and
I'm happy I'm leaving them very
beautiful experience and I'm very young
so I think that it's a perfect moment to
keep growing as an artist and as a
person too
[Music]
the 23 year old heartthrob isn't ready
to talk romance but family that's a
different story
you said you want to be a young dad why
is that a priority for you you want to
be like a real real dad young I don't
know when he's not the right mom and
right now because I'm working I have a
lot of things happen in my life my mind
but yeah before thirties I think I will
I want to have a child my Lumas top
priority at the moment crossing over to
the English language market with his new
album Fame faith Alma music essence I
think it's gonna be something new
there's gonna be a next maluma step and
I was working with all the biggest
producers of the industry Mayer American
industry I was working with Timbaland
burns Jay cash was a great experience to
sing for the first time in English
experiment a new sounds mix in this
American industry with the light
industry live music with American music
so that's gonna be like the perfect
balance in the India boom let's let's
see if you appreciate you're gonna like
it 21 cities the faint or taking the
United States by storm I'm ready to
dance what do you have in store for us
well I'm ready to dance - he's gonna be
is gonna be awesome and we're doing like
arenas like big concerts I'm pretty
excited I have a few surprises Davao
dancers double lights we're gonna have
incredible show you guys gonna cry then
you're gonna start jumping then I have
I'll have a lot of surprise for you
[Music]